[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer
hier sind wir wieder Mirko Kasimir und
Toni Heyer willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland und heute wird es mal wieder
sehr sehr finster
[Musik]
ich sah vor mir einen Wald von kruz
ifer die sich nach und nach und Bäume
verwandelten
zuerst schien es Tau oder Regen zu sein
der von den besten tropfte aber als ich
näher kam erkannte ich dass es Blut war
der ganze Wald begann sich zu winden und
die Bäume dunkel und aufrecht trifften
vor Blut
ein Mann ging von Baum zu bauen und fing
das Blut auf
ist der Becher voll war trat ein mich
heran
trink sagte er
Mirko was sind das für ein Einstieg was
haben wir da gerade gehört ach nur eine
Aussage von John George hey vor Gericht
ah klar was man halt so erzählt wenn man
angeklagt ist sechs Menschen ermordet
und ihre Leichen in säurebädern
aufgelöst zu haben und seinen Hals im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes aus der
Schlinge ziehen will Blut trinken
säurebäder ihr merkt schon heute geht es
wieder richtig ab aber ob John George
seinen Kopf aus der Schlinge ziehen
konnte das erfahrt ihr erst noch erstmal
die ist der Kopf denn da überhaupt
reingekommen Mirko na okay von Anfang an
John hey wird 1909 in England geboren
der Junge John hay ist ein braves Kind
ein richtiger Chorknabe also ein
richtiger Chorknabe im Knabenchor der
Kathedrale von Wake field er lernt
Klavier spielen und ist damit auch
ziemlich erfolgreich er errint sogar ein
Stipendium der Queen Elizabeth grammar
school wegfield da klingt nach einer
Bilderbuch Kindheit aber die Eltern
gehören einer strengen puritanischen
Sekte an Sport ist verboten mit anderen
Kindern darf er keinen Umgang pflegen
und die einzige Unterhaltung sind
Bibelverse immer wieder sind da die
Ermahnungen der Eltern der Herr sehe
jede Sünde und würde ihn bestrafen der
Vater zeigt seinem Sohn ein blaues mal
auf seinem Kopf das sei eine Strafe
Gottes weil er in seiner Jugend
gesündigt habe und werde es ganz genauso
ergehen wenn er sich nur den kleinsten
Fehltritt Leiste die Mutter hat kein
solches mal das liege logisch daran dass
sie ein Engel sei dem Jungen macht das
wie man sich vorstellen kann eine Höllen
Angst zumindest eine Zeit lang welcher
kleine Junge hätte schon allzu lange aus
ohne ein bisschen zu schwindeln etwas
heimlich zu naschen oder was auch immer
kleine Jungs sonst noch für Sachen
machen die laut streng religiösen Eltern
eine Sünde sind
john ist er natürlich keine Ausnahme
doch seltsam ist er hat keinen blauen
Fleck auf der Stirn ja und dafür gibt es
nur zwei mögliche Erklärungen entweder
all diese Geschichten sind Unsinn oder
aber John ist unverwundbar und nicht
einmal Gott persönlich kann ihn für
irgendetwas zur Rechenschaft ziehen und
es scheint dass John eher zur zweiten
Erklärung tendiert nach der Schule
beginnt er eine Lehre in einer Firma für
Motorentechnik die gibt er aber nach
einem Jahr auf und nimmt stattdessen
Jobs in der Versicherungs- und
Werbebranche an
Versicherung und Werbung ich will ja
nicht fies sein aber manche würden sagen
dass er damit schon auf die schiefe Bahn
geraten ist aber wie auch immer bald
wird er nämlich wirklich kriminell mit
21 Jahren steht er eine Geldkassette und
wird gefeuert daraufhin beginnt der
autodokumente zu fälschen um so sein
Geld zu verdienen und natürlich das geht
nicht lange gut
wird bald erwischt und sitzt seine erste
Haftstrafe ab 1936 kommt er wieder frei
und arbeitet eine Zeit lang als
Chauffeur und wartet Spielautomaten dann
beginnt er sich als Anwalt auszugeben
und gefälschte Aktien zu verkaufen er
fliegt auf als jemand einen
Rechtschreibfehler im Briefkopf des
vermeintlichen Anwalts bemerkt ein
kleines Detail aber ganz ärgerlich für
ihn hey wird so vier Jahren Haft
verurteilt und nutzt die Zeit um sich
fortzubilden na wenn man das so nennen
möchte na das klingt ein bisschen zu
harmlos fast wie ein Töpferkurs an der
Volkshochschule aber hey lernt in der
zinnwerkstatt das Gefängnisses den
Umgang mit Schwefelsäure und probiert
dabei an Mäusen aus was sie an
organischem Gewebe anrichtet ihr könnt
es euch wahrscheinlich schon denken aber
von den Mäusen bleibt nicht viel übrig
und hey denkt darüber nach dass er nicht
im Gefängnis sitzen würde wenn sich die
Opfer seiner Betrügereien in Luft
bzw Säure aufgelöst hätten statt der
Polizei zu gehen
eine Idee nimmt Gestalt an
1940 kommt der jetzt 30-Jährige wieder
auf freien Fuß beginnt sofort wieder mit
seinen kleinen Betrüger rein und landet
schnell wieder im Knast nach seiner
Freilassung 1944 trifft er in einem Pub
in London zufällig auf Donald Max War
One die beiden kennen sich seit hey
einige Jahre zuvor für Donalds Vater
William MC Swan einen reichen
Geschäftsmann als Chauffeur gearbeitet
hat beim fliegen die beiden ein
freundschaftliches Verhältnis so scheint
es zumindest am 6 september 1944 wird
klar dass sich Donald da aber mal so
richtig den falschen Freund ausgesucht
hat hey lockt den ahnungslosen in den
Keller seines Hauses schlägt ihm mit
einem bleiro über den Kopf schlitzt ihm
die Kehle auf und steckt die Leiche in
ein fassen 180 m hoch konzentrierte
Schwefelsäure
zwei Tage später sind von Donald Max
warn nur noch undefinierbare Klumpen in
einer trüben Flüssigkeit übrig hey
entleert die Überreste in einem Gulli
und besucht Donalds Eltern
ihr Sohn habe sich nach Schottland
abgesetzt und teilte sich versteckt um
der Einberufung zum Kriegsdienst zu
entgehen erklärte zumindest den Eltern
das klingt plausibel offensichtlich
hatte Donald auch ihn gegenüber
klargestellt dass er auf gar keinen Fall
eingezogen und an die Front geschickt
werden wolle hey der gute Freund zog
schließlich für eine Weile bei den
Eltern seines ersten Mordopfers ein und
begann wieder für den Vater William MC
Swan zu arbeiten nur warum kam Donald
nach Kriegsende nicht zurück seit dem
Frühjahr 1945 Fragen die Max immer
wieder nach
bis hazy am 2 juli in sein Haus lockt
der Sohn sei zu einem
Überraschungsbesuch da und erwarte sie
ja statt dem Sohn erwartet die Eltern
ein säurebart hey er schlägt die beiden
und löst ihre Leichen wie die ihre
Sohnes in Schwefelsäure auf dann steht
er die pensionsschecks des Vaters und
verkauft mit Hilfe gefälschter Dokumente
das Eigentum der Eltern
seit er donnert maxwern getroffen hat
ist das sein eigentliches Ziel gewesen
doch das Geld reicht nicht lange hey ist
ein Spieler schnell ist er wieder pleite
und sucht sich das nächste Opfer er
mietet eine kleine Werkstatt in der
Ortschaft Trolley ins hasse Sex und
transportiert Fässer und Säure aus dem
Keller seines Hauses in London dorthin
in London hat er das Ehepaar Rose und
Archibald Henderson kennengelernt und
eine freundschaftliche Beziehung zu ihm
aufgebaut am 12 februar 1946 lockt der
Archibald Henderson in seine Werkstatt
nach 6 vorgeblich um ihm eine Erfindung
zu zeigen dort erschießt er ihn mit
einem Revolver den er dem Arzt zuvor
gestohlen hat dann holt er raus zu Hause
ab ihr Mann sei plötzlich krank geworden
und sie müssen mit ihm kommen erschießt
auch sie dann wirft er die Leichen in
Schwefelsäure doch etwas geht schief
von Archibald Henderson bleibt ein Fuß
intakt den Mörder kümmert es nicht er
kippt die Reste achtlos unter einen
Holunderbaum in einer Ecke des
werkstatthofes ja schließlich ist er
unverwundbar also wenn Gott ihm für
seine Jugendsünden keinen blauen Fleck
verpasst hat was sollen ihm dann bitte
weltliche Kräfte anhaben können also
fälscht er wieder Dokumente und
angebliche Briefe der Hände sind und
verkauft ihren Besitz und wieder ist das
Geld schnell aufgebraucht
1948 plant er den nächsten Mord er hat
inzwischen henrieta Helen Olivia Roberts
kennengelernt eine wohlhabende Dame von
69 Jahren sie lebt im selben Londoner
Hotel in dem hey es sich seit dem
letzten Mord gut gehen lässt
die beiden lernen sich im Restaurant des
Hotels kennen
sie hat eine Methode erfunden künstliche
Fingernägel herzustellen und hey
präsentiert sich ihr als idealer
Geschäftspartner am 18 Februar ändert
sie in einem Fass mit Schwefelsäure in
John Hays Werkstatt in Sussex die
Überreste landen unter dem Holunderbaum
ich will ja nicht sagen aber Mirko ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das so
gut für einen Baum ist ganz sicher nicht
danach geht jedenfalls alles sehr
schnell zwei Tage nach dem Verschwinden
von Helen Duran Deacon meldet ein Freund
sie als vermisst ein Polizist besucht
das Hotel und erkennt in einem der
Dauergäste einen alten Bekannten
den Typen da den haben wir doch schon
ein paar mal wegen betrugsfest gesetzt
hey wird verhört und gibt zu mit der
alten Dame bekannt und verabredet
gewesen zu sein sie sei aber nicht
erschienen er habe sich selbst schon
gewundert aber einem notorischen
Betrüger glaubt man nicht so leicht die
Polizei durchsucht seine Werkstatt und
findet dort Fässer die Spuren von
Schwefelsäure aufweisen außerdem leere
schwefelsäure-behälter eine Uhr die
offenbar misses tourent Deacon gehört
hat und weitere belastende Indizien den
Mörder juckt das wenig ohne Leiche kein
Mord das ist zumindest seine Meinung die
Polizei sieht das ganz anders und
außerdem sind die Gerichtsmediziner
fündig geworden im Hof unter dem
Holunderbaum finden Sie unter anderem
nurco 28 Pfund menschliches Körperfett
drei Gallensteine Teile eines Fußes der
hat einmal Arsch über den Henderson
gehört 18 Knochen Fragmente
oberes sowie ein unteres Gebiss hey wird
verhaftet und angeklagt und jetzt fragt
ihr euch vielleicht was ist eigentlich
mit diesen blutenden Bäumen und dem
Trinkbecher Vollblut also den Mirko da
am Anfang so gruselig erzählt hat das
sind Teile von Hays
Verteidigungsstrategie er gibt alle
Morde zu ihm wird wohl bald klar dass es
keinen Zweck gehabt hätte irgendetwas
abzustreiten aber er gibt vor aufgrund
seiner psychiatrischen Erkrankung nicht
schuldfähig zu sein um dem Galgen zu
entgehen Schuld an allem seien seine
Eltern und ihre Rose Religiosität
erleide unter schrecklichen Albträumen
wie mit diesen komischen blutbäumen und
er spüre den ununterdrückbaren Wunsch
Blut zu trinken nur deshalb habe er die
Morde begangen das Geld sei neben Sache
gewesen und er will das Blut jedes
Opfers getrunken haben bevor er sie in
die säurefässer geworfen hat aber das
kann nie nachgewiesen werden Gutachter
und nicht glauben dem notorischen
Betrüger der so oft bewiesen hat was für
ein guter Lügner und Manipulator er ist
jedenfalls kein Wort die Presse dagegen
ist elektrisiert und berichtet vom
Vampir von London hey nutzt das alles
nichts am 10 August 1949 wird John high
in London gehängt der
unverwundbare ist tot und eine der
grausigsten Mordserien ihrer Zeit hat
ein Ende gefunden und ich muss sagen ich
finde das absolut richtig dass ihm
niemand diese wilden Fantasien geglaubt
hat also blutbäume das ist ja völlig
absurd jetzt nichts gegen Menschen die
wirklich psychische Probleme haben aber
der hat ja sein ganzes Leben lang an
einem Gott Komplex schon fast gelitten
und nur gelogen hat er ernsthaft
geglaubt er kommt damit durch
aber gut Gott sei Dank war dem nicht so
[Musik]
das war die Geschichte vom Säurebad
Mörder oder auch dem Vampir von London
wir haben Sie anhand von Beiträgen bei
crime and
investigation.co.uk
mörderpedia.com und einem Spiegelartikel
aus dem Jahr 1949 erzählt wir danken
euch fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten
Mal euer Mirko und eure Toni Redaktion
Stefan Netzeband Skript und
Postproduktion Waker Studios